we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
and i hate that this is going on but the
anti-vaccine crowd
the the covid anti-vaccine crowd
is getting very belligerent and starting
to adopt more and more
violent rhetoric uh here is an
anti-vaccine guy who's been calling me
for a couple of weeks and he's getting
more and more fired up take a listen
hey david sarah from mass again i just
wanted to uh
ask you um you must have some really
good lawyers uh backing you up because
the stuff you're saying
and the advice you're given non-medical
about an experimental vaccine
remember i give no advice
that i come up with on this program i
state what medical uh
authorities and public health experts
say much like joe biden didn't decide
masks can come off outdoors joe biden
accepts
the expertise of the cdc so
there's been no original vaccine claims
made on this program i think it's
important
to to point out and a lot of people
don't seem to understand that i'm not
coming up with this stuff on my own
i mean you can get in some serious
trouble here if someone blames you or
something there's a lot of crazy people
out there
obviously i couldn't but i understand
the thinly veiled threat thank you
they're gonna listen to your stupid
advice and the things you're saying
about getting kids vaccined
with a non-fda approved experimental
vaccine what are you
crazy right so this is what we are up
against
if we are going to lose the fight
against the pandemic
we have the tools if we were vaccinating
4 million a day right now
instead of 2 million a day which now is
limited
only by lack of interest the u.s you
know there's countries desperate for
supply
we have the supply we have we have a
lack of enough interest so vaccinations
have been declining uh
we could be far closer to ending this
thing
if it weren't for the point of view of
people like this guy
so uh that's extraordinarily dangerous
that the
the rhetoric is getting more violent and
i don't know what the outcome is going
to be
but that is some really scary stuff we
have
a fantastic bonus show for you today
we are going to talk about the florida d
platforming
law and its constitutional very
interesting issue
that relates to free speech it relates
to digital freedom and so much more
we are also going to talk about
increasingly those
who is going to suffer in the future
from
the lack of attention to the climate
crisis today well it's those who are now
children
and children are increasingly taking
governments to court over climate
and they're starting to win they are
starting to win and we will talk about
that and lastly
is it time for the fda to ban
all menthol cigarettes some of you would
say all cigarettes should be banned but
we are specifically going to talk about
what's going on with menthol cigarettes
on the bonus show today
i had no idea that this was a
source of such controversy controversy
controversy and concern among the
medical community
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
memorial day okay very special day
we will be off there will be no show on
memorial day
it'll be a perfect holiday but we will
we will also be doing a single day
membership special
one day huge ungodly discount haven't
done this for months and months
if you would like to be notified of that
membership special
on may 31st it's as simple as going to
my website
and signing up for my newsletter that is
it my friends that is it
i will see you on the bonus show
momentarily